hey everyone this is Lucy and in this
video I'll be walking you through five
mini AWS Cloud projects these projects
will only take you a few hours to build
and you can add them onto your resume or
portfolio to Showcase your hands-on
experience we're going to start off with
a super basic beginner friendly project
and then we'll move on to some more
intermediate and advanced ones that will
give you a deeper knowledge of AWS a big
thank you to today's sponsor coding Dojo
but more about them later in the video
alright let's just dive straight into it
the first Cloud project is to host your
own website on AWS you might have come
across website builders in the past like
Squarespace or webflow that make it
super easy for you to launch a designer
website but the problem is it doesn't
teach you about the underlying
technology or what happens behind the
scenes to get the website up and running
in fact many large companies prefer to
set up their websites on AWS because it
provides them with extra flexibility and
scalability for the web infrastructure
and it's also much cheaper this is why I
recommend learning how to host a static
website on AWS as your first Cloud
project it's probably not the most
exciting project on the list but before
we move on to the more fun ones it's
important to understand the basics and
web hosting is definitely one of the
fundamental use cases that every cloud
engineer or Solutions architect should
know now there are many ways to host a
website on AWS but here's what I
recommend doing step number one design
your own website using HTML and CSS or
download an existing website template
step number two setup and configure an
Amazon S3 bucket to store your website
files step number three purchase the
custom domain through Amazon Route 53
and connect it with an S3 bucket once
that's done you'll be able to view and
access your website through the custom
link I actually have a step-by-step
video tutorial for this project that
I'll link in the description below and
if you prefer to read the instructions
I'll also have a link to my GitHub repo
with a document sharing a more detailed
guide on how you can set up the project
here you'll find step-by-step
instructions for all five projects in
this video as well as some additional
resources to help you out if you get
stuck overall this first project should
only take you about 30 minutes to one
hour if you want to use an existing
template but it could take longer if you
decide to customize your website design
before hosting it once some building you
can add this line onto your resume and
move on to project number two okay
project number two is where things start
to get interesting in this project
you'll be visualizing data through
charts and dashboards on Amazon
quickside you'll start by downloading a
data set of 50 000 best-selling Amazon
products and store it into an Amazon S3
bucket and then you're going to connect
that S3 bucket with Amazon quicksite to
create a few interesting visualizations
from that data again I have a video
tutorial for this one as well so you'll
be able to follow along step by step and
you'll also be able to find written
instructions on my GitHub page this
project should only take you about one
to two hours to complete and once you're
done building the project you can add
this line onto your resume okay so those
were the two beginner level projects
let's move on to the more intermediate
ones project number three is where your
integrated Amazon Lex chatbot with
Facebook Messenger you could use this to
create a customer service chatbot a
booking system or even a trivia game but
I'll leave it up to you to explore and
get creative with what you want your
chatbot to do but for now let's break
down the process into simple steps so
that you can get started the first step
is to create an Amazon Lex chatbot with
a name a voice and a session timeout
next create a Facebook page an app
through the Facebook developer portal
set up a webhook to receive messages
from Facebook users after that integrate
the Amazon next chatbot with Facebook
messenger and make sure you configure
the correct settings and the last step
is to test your chatbot and make any
improvements that you'd like once you've
completed the project you can add this
line onto your resume and as I mentioned
earlier you can really get creative with
this project and build something
interesting alright project number four
is another fun one we're going to build
a fortune teller application now this
application can't actually tell your
fortune and you probably shouldn't take
any advice from it but what you can do
is ask any question that you like and
the application will tell you yes or no
for example if you ask should I have a
pizza for lunch the application would
either reply with yes no or maybe here's
how you build it so first set up an AWS
Lambda function and configure the
necessary settings next write the code
for generating random responses using
Python's random module after that set up
an API Gateway integrated with the
Lambda function and once that's done
deploy your code and test it to see if
the application runs properly once the
project is completed add this line onto
your resume to describe what you built I
don't have a video tutorial for this
project unfortunately but let me know in
the comments below if you'd like me to
record one now before we move on to the
next AWS project which is more of an
advanced one I'd like to tell you about
coding Dojo a coding bootcamp that
offers full-time and part-time classes
in software development data science and
cyber security unlike many boot camps
that specialize in one stack coding
dojo's three-stack curriculum provides
graduates with a complete skill set for
example students can start by learning
JavaScript then move on to another
programming language and after that
another one this equips them with the
ability to easily learn new technologies
and languages as they come up in their
career at coding Dojo students learn by
doing they get the chance to Tinker with
code make mistakes and continue to
practice and improve over time and
unlike other boot camps their graduates
get a lifetime of support from their
Career Services team if you're new to
coding and want to learn the basics
coding Dojo offers free intro to web
development and intro to python
workshops these quick two to three hour
workshops will immerse you into the
world of programming and web development
you might even pick up some fundamental
skills that can help you get started so
if you're interested in check out coding
Dojo head to the link in the description
below to find out more thank you coding
dojo for sponsoring this video okay
finally we have project number five
where our goal is to build a multi-tier
highly available thought tolerant web
application the good news is even though
this is more of an advanced project AWS
has a step-by-step tutorial that
explains exactly how to build everything
I won't talk too much about this one
because all the instructions are
available over here but I'll leave a
link in the description below for you to
try it out yourself here's a sneak peek
of the architecture of what you'll end
up with as you can see here there's a
VPC with six subnets and internet
gateway and Amazon S3 bucket and a few
other AWS Services being used and there
you have it five AWS Cloud projects to
help you get Hands-On get hired and
Advance your career if you found this
video helpful please remember to give it
a like and let me know in the comments
below which project was your favorite
alright bye for now
foreign